effectivement louis de funès comme
disait marcel achard à manger de la
vache enragée et encore pas tous les
jours pendant longtemps il est né à
courbevoie à la veille de la guerre de
et pour payer ses études de comédie il a
à peu près tout fait il a été
dessinateur il a été fourrure il était
étalagiste et même photographe c'est
daniel jeulin qui lui a donné le virus
de la comédie
alors effectivement son premier film
date de 45
et c'est là dans la tentation de
barbizon qu'il ouvrait fermer une porte
à la même époque on se souvient d'un
tramway nommé désir où il disait deux
mots il est ma veste avec acharnement il
a poursuivi sa carrière la fois au
théâtre et au cinéma il a il a joué une
centaine de petits rôles et on peut dire
que la gloire est venu avec la la
traversée de paris de claude autant lara
et les belles bacchantes de robert dhéry
et puis pour le théâtre c'était avec
oscar alors on connaît la suite je ne
vais pas énumérer tous les succès qui à
partir des années 60 ont fait de louis
de funès
le premier comique français ce que je
vous propose c'est de le retrouver
il nous expliquait en mars 79 les
caractères de son comique et puis il
ajoutait aussi quelques mots concernant
sa retraite nantel je ne fais pas je
fais la tête que font les gens beaucoup
de gens font ça parce que dira insee
doivent se reconnaître
vous les observez beaucoup vous noté
primal timbre avril depuis toujours
malgré moi et ça ça se neutralisent là
alors je dois voir une un petit petit
ordinateur était sa vie à la demande
c'est des choses que j'ai vu qu'à 20 ans
30 ans il nous reste laurel et hardy
chaque ligne entendu harry langdon et
voilà des acteurs tout ça qu'ils
n'étaient pas des ct d'abeilles aussi
fields au site c'est ça que j'adore et
c'est ça que je voudrais continuer à
faire j'étais impressionné par sa dans
le comique ça c'est mon vrai comique ta
vie un comique de situation saleh c'est
là que la situation s'est toujours les
la plus grande situation du monde c'est
un monsieur qui lit son journal avec une
chaise quelqu'un s'approche on nous fout
une bombe là dessous et il y tourne les
pages
il n'y a pas et je voudrais arriver à
faire un film comique à biot
un film un film muet mais c'est très
difficile à effet mais pas muet comme du
temps du muet mais avec tous les bruits
les sons mais où les gens s'ils n'ont
pas parlé depuis dimanche pour au bout
des mots qui parlent de votre jardin
c'est un mot qui paraît très douce
entendu nos beaux jardinage part des
choses
ces ouvriers transportés dans des
brouettes qui font dans autant de kilos
d avec 30 40 50 kg mais c'était un
traître le jardin est un très très gros
travail mais c'est ce qui m'a sauvé ça
va bien c'est une santé sauver tout ça
parce que j'ai une petite chose car dit
avec tant de fois il ya déjà quatre ans
et c'est le jardin qui me sauve si
j'étais resté à paris je serais plus de
ce monde là déjà
oui